hey everybody
danny here with chess.com i'm joined
here by the man magnus carlson you can
see fresh off an ftx crypto cup victory
in miami uh because we're here to share
some pretty exciting news
uh i will i will start and say that
chess.com has made an offer for play
magnus to join chess.com and we're
pretty excited about it magnus i'll turn
it over to you
yeah
that is true we've had a process that's
lasted a
few few months i feel like we've had
a very uh very positive experience there
talking about the possibilities for the
future
and i'm very excited to uh to be part of
it
yeah
yeah like magnus said it's been a bit of
a process and it the process is still
not complete it'll actually be about six
to eight weeks and until then uh for
those who will already be asking and
buzzing about this chess.com and play
magnus will remain separate companies
but at the end of this process uh we'll
be able to share a lot more about all
the things that um
that are in the future the stuff that we
feel excited about doing together
speaking for not just
myself and magnus and the conversations
we've had but for all the team members
who have been involved in this so um i
think the most exciting thing i can
speak for everyone is me and magnus
doing funny
funny tick tock videos together magnus
um well as soon as i learn what tik tok
is i'm sure i'll be happy to join we've
got a lot a lot to a lot to talk about
and the future is is going to have so
much more of it so i i want to express
my appreciation uh for for magnus and
the entire play magnus group in terms of
getting here my excitement for what
we're gonna do um and um
all the things in store magnus magnus
playing in and winning a lot more a lot
more title tuesdays and other events um
in the future what event are you most
excited to be winning on a regular basis
wow that's a difficult uh
question
i think so far
i am at least um shared first in all the
title tuesdays i've played although
there haven't been
many so
i'll try to keep that streak going apart
from that i'm excited to uh
to play in the speed chess championship
again um i have a score to settle
obviously after the last time i played
and lost in the semifinals uh but uh
generally just happy to be playing
top top level events on uh on a regular
basis
yup
magnus congrats on miami thanks for
thanks for doing this quickly before you
hop on a plane to wherever you're going
next and um i'm going future first time
two
oh man that's wild right chennai miami
going home so all right man um
how do i how do i end this video this is
my job and i'm supposed to end this
video professionally what should we do
do you know how to end this
it ended 30 seconds ago bye
guys
[Music]
ended 30 seconds ago bye i love that
don't leave don't leave
we need you to stay on for a little bit
let the video upload them we're at 25
i have a flight in a little less than
five hours
i mean in terms of this uploading in
time for
that was the joke um we're halfway there
50 50
uploaded anyway um
my phone is about a million degrees now
he dropped danny oh we lost
magnus is it is it is he done uploading
no we gotta get him back
[Music]
uh i was kicked out for some reason okay
he's back it looks like it's still
uploading
two hours later yeah i don't think hotel
wi-fi here in miami is the fastest way
magnus your uh upload just finished so
it's all locked in yes all right man i
appreciate you thanks for being patient
with the upload have you have a great
flight thank you and uh i'm excited to
be uh i'm excited to be part of the part
of this so
i'm
looking forward to the fresh release as
well appreciate it man
okay all right thank you